donc j'ai toujours aimé observer le ciel
j'ai toujours aimé le sentiment de
vertige qui vient avec de sentir si
petit dans l'immensité de l'univers et
ce qui est fascinant c'est que qu'on
observe le ciel la seule information
qu'on peut obtenir des astres c'est la
lumière qu'il nous envoie la lumière
elle est composée de photons et le
photon il le message est le seul message
est on ne peut pas les toucher les
étoiles le photon est la seule
information qu'on peut obtenir
les lumières le photon voyagent à la
vitesse de la lumière soit trois cent
mille kilomètres par seconde donc pour
vous donner un exemple ça prend une
seconde la lumière pour faire le chemin
de la lune à la terre
un photon qui part de mars doit voyager
en moyenne une quinzaine de minutes
avant d'atteindre la paire
pour jupiter planète un peu plus loin
c'est environ 45 minutes de voyage en
moyenne
la première étoile qu'on va trouver en
sortant du système solaire l'étoile la
plus proche de nous et les situer à 4
années lumière ce à dire que la lumière
prend quatre années un voyage est un
photo qui parle de l'étoile va prendre
quatre années à rejoindre la terre
la galaxie d'andromède keynote de nos
plus proches voisines et les situe à 2.2
millions d'années lumière donc la
lumière voyage et 2.2 millions d'années
pour nous rejoindre quand on s'éloigne
encore on arrive à des des plus grandes
structures dans l'univers des amas de
galaxies
la mode galaxie convola est situé entre
50 et 100 millions d'années lumière donc
imaginez les photons qu'on voit
aujourd'hui de ces galaxies la
15e qu'elles ont amorcé leur voyage y
avait encore des dinosaures sur terre
et finalement ici on voit une image une
des plus profonde jamais prise ça a été
pris par le télescope hubble on voit
dans cette image là des galaxies
qui sont situées à 13 milliards
d'années-lumière on les voit comme l
était il ya 13 milliards d'années ce
sont les premières galaxies qui sont
formés après le big bang donc la lumière
est un formidable
formidable machine à voyager dans le
temps
j'ai toujours été impressionné par les
lumières par l'astronomie mais j'ai
aussi j'aimais beaucoup quand j'étais
petit l'électronique l'informatique et
la photographie j'ai beaucoup
expérimenté avec un vieil appareil photo
de mes parents pendant que ça fonctionne
encore avec des films
et après un baccalauréat en génie
électrique
j'ai eu envie de retourner à cette
première première passion qui est l
astrophysique donc chez lui cogner à la
porte de l'université de montréal où
département d'astrophysique pour savoir
si je pouvais continuer des études
gratuit après un baccalauréat en génie
électrique et j'ai eu de la chance parce
qu'on cherchait quelqu'un qui avait mon
profil pour commencer à travailler sur
un nouveau type de caméra alors pendant
ma maîtrise j'ai eu la chance d'observer
sur certains des plus grands télescopes
du monde et j'ai été fasciné par le défi
n'est générée qu'ils représentent
les télescopes sont souvent construits
sur le sommet des montagnes des lieux
quasi inaccessible même des fois c'est
sur d'anciens volcans et certains
télescopes sont situés si haut en
altitude qu'on doit faire des paliers
d'adaptation pour être capable de les
observer
pour vous donner un exemple de leur
extrême précision
les télescopes souvent sont faits à
partir d'un miroir et si on voit c'est
un télescope le miroir fait huit mètres
de diamètre les poly à la perfection et
donner un exemple en fait si on étendait
le miroir entre montréal et new york la
plus petite imperfection sur le miroir
frais seulement quelques millimètres
donc les télescopes sont des machines à
collecter les photons d'une extrême
précision ils vont voir ils vont prendre
les photos qui arrivent des confins de
l'espace se refléter sur le miroir ils
vont être dirigés vers
une caméra ou les photos vont être la
lumière va être accumulés et là on va
pouvoir l'étudier mais c'est souvent là
où j'ai trouvé que les choses se gâtent
et
ça arrive trop souvent que les photons
qui qui frappait la caméra ils étaient
perdus tout simplement donc si on
regarde comment devrait se comporter une
caméra parfaite quand il ya beaucoup de
lumière on devrait avoir une très belle
image et à au fur et à mesure où on
diminue la quantité de lumière qui
frappe la caméra on se ramasse ce qui
nous mangent de plus en plus granuleuse
comme ça jusqu'à finalement être formé
par seulement des 0 et des 1 donc zéro
étant un pixel de la caméra qui a vu
aucune lumière 0 photo un étang un pixel
la caméra qui a vu en photo ils vous
remarquerez autour de la lune ici on
voit encore on a on peut encore avoir
une dès que c'est la lune convoi mais
surtout autour n'y avait pas de lumière
et y la caméra n'a rien vu donc quand il
ya du noir une caméra parfaite devrait
voir briller mais souvent ce qui arrive
la fosse lumière qui est générée par la
caméra ce qu'on appelle du bruit qui
vont venir noyer la faible le faible
signal qu'on a reçues désastre est en
fait un défi que je me suis lancé de
réussir à améliorer le sort de ces
pauvres photons qui avait voyagé si
longtemps
donc j'ai étudié un peu comme en
commun de quoi était composé une caméra
on peut diviser 102 en deux modules
c'est paris le premier temps le
détecteur qui est un peu comme l'oeil de
la caméra et le deuxième étant composé
de circuits électroniques
ce qu'on appelle le contrôleur qui est
un peu comme le cerveau la caméra donc
le cerveau interprète ce que l'oeil a vu
les yeux qu'on a les yeux électroniques
ont aujourd'hui les détecteurs qu'on a à
ils sont presque parfait ils peuvent
détecter 95 % de la lumière qui leur
tombent dessus il ya très peu de petits
mise à sion qu'on peut faire de ce côté
là et en étudiant un peu plus j'ai vu
que la fosse lumière qui était
génériques ont observé dans les images
c'était en fait le cerveau de la caméra
qui
pilotait mal l'oeil et qui interprétait
mal en fait ce que l'oeil lui retourner
donc pour mon doctorat je me suis lancé
comme défi de refaire complètement
l'électronique des caméras pour être
capable de diminuer la quantité de
fausses lumière qui étaient générés
c'était un défi risqué il rien qui me
prouvait que ça pouvait fonctionner et
on devait vraiment jusqu'à concevoir un
nouveau contrôleur pour pouvoir tester
les résultats
j'étais chanceux ç'a bien fonctionné
j'ai réussi à diminuer d'un facteur dix
la quantité de fausses lumière générée
par les caméras donc de réussir à créer
une caméra qui dans les conditions de
très faible lumière se comportait comme
une caméra parfaite du coup ça en a fait
la caméra la plus sensible au monde
c'était un peu obligé parce que
simplement j'avais réussi à améliorer ce
qui était déjà
presque idéale mais ç'a permis des
belles applications pour
tester la sensibilité de la caméra je
les amener à l'observatoire du mont
mégantic et j ai fait des observations
de galaxies dans des conditions de très
faible lumière
donc si je montre en accéléré
une observation de environ trois heures
où la caméra accumulent les fautes ont
un arbre et
créer une image on convoi le centre de
la galaxie qui est et qui très lumineux
donc qui apparaît en premier et à mesure
que le temps passe on voit
tranquillement se dessiner les régions
périphériques de la galaxie les régions
où il ya moins de lumière
après environ trois heures d'observation
la caméra avait capturé trois millions
de photos provenant la galaxie donc 3
millions ça peut être un chiffre qui
nous semble gros mais pour vous donner
un ordre de grandeur si on considère une
ampoule de 100 watts qu'on a tous le
monde dans nos maisons les ampoules de
100 watts voix et m cent mille milliards
de fois plus de lumière en une seconde
qu'est ce que la caméra avait pu voir de
la galaxie en trois heures donc c'est
vraiment saisi l'ultime sensibilité
et en fait j'ai comparé les résultats
de la nouvelle caméra par rapport à ce
qui était le plus sensible à l'époque
voici ce qu'on voyait avant et voici ce
qu'on a réussi à avoir sur le même
télescope le même instrument dans des
conditions d'observation enfin
comparables
avant gauche a pris à droite
j'ai pu mesurer que la caméra était
quatre fois plus sensibles c'est à dire
que on peut avoir la même qualité
d'image en quatre fois moins de temps
donc ceux qui prenaient une heure à
obtenir avant prenez 15 minutes et qu'on
pense que souvent le temps une nuit sur
un grand télescope peut coûter entre 35
et 50 mille dollars
ben d'être capable de faire la même
chose en quatre fois moins de temps ça
son intérêt
les gens avec qui je travaillais à
l'époque que les gens de la compagnie
photos et de chez terra montréal
m'ont convaincu que si la caméra pour
être si bonne sur un télescope elles
pouvaient l'être tout aussi
avantageuse pour un microscope parce
qu'en effet pour la caméra en photo si
un photos qu'ils viennent d'une cellule
qui est saoul
l'objectif du microscope ou qui viennent
des confins de l'univers c'est c'est un
photon équivalent elle fait pas d'âgisme
donc
si on reprend 1,7
cette image de comparaison la
c'est une galaxie qu'on voit
présentement imaginez maintenant que
c'est une cellule cancéreuse parc
laquelle des deux caméras ce que vous
aimeriez le mieux être diagnostiqués
c'est la réflexion qui a mené à la
création d'un nouveau caméra une
compagnie que j'ai cofondé en 2010 et on
s'est donné comme mission de prendre la
technologie développée pour l'astronomie
de l'amener vers le domaine biomédical
donc prendre la caméra développé pour
les microscopes
de l'amener vers les microscopes
une manière simple d'utiliser notre
notre caméra s'est simplement de prendre
une caméra d'un système existant et de
la remplacer
donc c'est ce qu'on a fait avec des
chercheurs amaigri au laboratoire de
microscopie confocale il avait un
microscope et une caméra pour observer
un atom 1 point à tomber une molécule
une cellule de pollen et voici ce qu'il
voyait avec leurs anciennes caméra voici
ce qu'on a réussi à obtenir avec la
nôtre il ya certaines structures dans
dans l'observation on a fait avec notre
caméra qu'on ne peut pas voir dans
l'autre donc le simple fait de changer
de caméra permettait
des nouvelles percées mais il ya mieux
il ya des chercheurs à l'école
polytechnique de montréal qui ont refait
complètement le microscope qui est
utilisé par le chirurgien pendant les
opérations cancer du cerveau
ils y ont attaché notre caméra avec
d'autres filtres spéciaux et ça permet
aux chirurgiens de voir en temps réel là
où se situent les cellules cancéreuses
pendant le pendant l'opération donc le
chirurgien peut savoir quelles régions
du cerveau sont saines quelles régions
du cerveau sont affectées par le cancer
ce qui est beaucoup à l'opération ce qui
diminue le change les chances de
récidive donc dans ce cas si
chaque photon est important parce que
chaque photon provient d'une cellule
cancéreuse est en fait chaque photo peut
sauver la vie du patient
d'autres applications la compagnie photo
et cetera toujours à montréal qui
conçoit des filtres spéciaux ont mis
notre caméra derrière
et on a fait un système pour être
capable d'observer ce qui se passe dans
dans dans le système nerveux un système
de neurones interconnectés
le défi là c'est d'être capable de
prendre des images très rapidement la
communication entre les neurones se fait
très rapidement et donc on a très peu de
temps en fait il ya très peu de temps
pour y mettre de la lumière et donc très
peu de temps pour la capter aussi donc
dans une application comme celle là où
on est capable de mesurer l'efficacité
de certains médicaments pour le
traitement de certaines maladies du
système nerveux on ne pourrait pas avoir
cette sensibilité là si on n'avait pas
une caméra qui est extrêmement sensible
un autre exemple au japon le japon a
investi des centaines de milliards 2
millions de dollars pour concevoir un
laser à rayons x on est habitué aux
petits une petite diode laser qu'on
utilise pour les présentations un laser
à rayons x un peu plus compliqué ça
prend un bâtiment de 300 mètres de long
pour être capable de générer et avec ça
ils ont pu faire un microscope tellement
puissant qui peut voir la matière à
l'échelle de l'atome on peut voir des
atomes individuelle et forcément il ya
très peu de lumière qui sort de ce
microscope lun 20 à tomb tout seul peut
pas y mettre beaucoup de lumière et
c'est la raison pour laquelle au bout de
ce bâtiment de 300 mètres de long ils
ont mis une autre caméra pour être
capable de voir les résultats de la
super microscope
mais malgré toutes ces applications très
terre-à-terre entend castro physicien je
peux pas m'empêcher de me demander
est-ce qu'on est seul dans l'univers
enfin j'imagine tout le monde ici sait
déjà posé la question
depuis 1995 on sait qu'il ya d'autres
planètes autour d'autres étoiles
en fait il y en a même beaucoup et en
2008 une équipe de l'université de
montréal et de la colombie britannique
qui ont été les premiers faire une photo
d'un système solaire extra s'avère donc
de systèmes planétaires extrasolaires
c'était une grande première c'est la
première fois qu'on peut voir des
étoiles des planètes tourner autour
d'une étoile
autre que le soleil et depuis ce temps
là ben si la course est toujours voir
plus toujours voir plus loin et
maintenant on essaie de trouver des
planètes qui pourrait ressembler à la
terre autour des toiles qui pourrait
ressembler au soleil pour essayer de
trouver des planètes qui pourrait
y avoir la vie
et la lumière qui nous provient de ces
planètes la très loin au taux de leur
peu de soleil
c'est très très peu de lumière qui nous
vient ces quelques photons par heure un
photon par heure essayez pas de le voir
avec vos yeux c'est impossible et donc
ça prend une caméra qui va être capable
vraiment de discerner il ya de la
lumière où il y en a pas ça prend deux
caméras ultra sensible et c'est la
raison en fait pour laquelle nos
technologies présentement est à l'étude
par l' agence spatiale canadienne et la
nasa pour un instrument qui permettrait
peut-être de voir l'équivalent de terre
autour d'autres étoiles
donc j'ai toujours aimé servi le ciel
mais aujourd'hui je prouve un vertige
encore plus grand quand je les regarde
quand je pense qu'avec le même
instrument on est capable de sonder les
confins de l'univers autant que les
atomes les cellules et et la vie
est en fait
avec notre caméra d'autant plus fier
qu'on n'y peut être capable de sauver
des vies sur terre et peut-être un jour
être capable de trouver la vie ailleurs
sur d'autres planètes